non senti che lo spirito famiglia perché
ciglio topi nel menù della agenti
ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su the
sims è una vita e mezza stai zitto è una
vita e mezzo che non faccio the sims
l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto sarà stato
quattro anni fa facciamo prima il mio
personaggio oggi facciamo tipo
impostazioni del sesso personalizzato
con il corpo latino al maschile
preferenza l'abbigliamento maschile il
sindaco tra entrare in gravidanza o
quasi è un maschio come il sito può
usare i gabinetti impieghi no perché una
pipì la faccio da seduto perché sono
pigro ok ragazzo inglese riesco a fare
il 3 2 1 potrebbe per qualche strano
motivo assomigliarmi sto cristiano per
qualche motivo non so io con una pessima
scelta di casini però di base sono io
diciamo willow creek mi sono la cosa più
bella
fatto ciò di fondi 20 milano mazza o
quanti soldi si fanno su youtube non
puoi permetterti lotto spetta che faccio
un po di click day per lo fa ci facciamo
questo mi sembra carino si può fare
andiamo la mia nuova casa in culo a
tutti modalità vivi
si si si vogliono sapere tutorial io so
come si gioca
cazzo quanto sono io regalo incredibile
sono troppo io è un quale sono cambiato
maglia lo fa videogiochi lo sapevo cosa
poteva fare solo un quello dove vai che
non c'è macabri se io non cammino così
ve lo posso assicurare
ma che figata si porta veramente la tv
se passano delle belle [ __ ] ecco la
corri corri subito
non lasciarti scappare lo che se corri
maledetto uomo che pensa solo alla tv
corrie chiama chiama urla urla fa
qualcosa i capelli madonna che problema
torna in casa prendi le pastiglie degli
evidenti problemi dove c'è un altro la
madonna mi grafica corri corri che cazzo
frate frate cosa fai lì veloce quanti
problema donna come si fa andare veloce
ma è così non ho mai visto una tipa che
mi aspetta
così tanto ragazzi questo è un gioco
fantasy buongiorno ti piace di
videogiochi a figure chiedi del fiki
fiki subito quasi sata ii step veloce i
problemi ai la storia marchiando io
vattene via testa di culo racconta una
storia coinvolgente lo sai che conosco
famigliari di vespa numeri casa mia
ormai casa miro aspetta aspetta sia
style.it prego che devono vedere che
questo succede in casa vai dove cazzo
fatta dagli stalli un attimo maledizione
va beh ti sei salvato il numero ve lo
zio sisto xi salvato zingari cori che ti
stanno rubando casa corri madonna garcia
sto gioco call of duty è più tranquillo
c'è una gran gnocca incredibile c'è
un'altra abbastanza [ __ ] e poi c'è il
tipo di prima con l'hamburger in mano sì
però non state le in entrata cioè voglio
dire entrate
mettetevi comodi nella mia regia enorme
anzi facciamo così parliamo con la tipa
quando parla fa schifo e gli insetti
vero zia anche la spazzatura amica fa
veramente schifo non sei a lui
questo sì che il mio ragazzo soffermino
domanda perché si è unito sto uomo al
buy via vai via allora francia ci sono
un sacco di tipo ma ce ne sono due hai
parlato appena come una roccia strafiga
e stai leggendo un libro che problemi
chiamarli sono spiega fai come lo può
essere come l'altro maledizione parlaci
queste ragazze sfoggia l'abito guarda
che se la stava rimorchiando più veloce
muti delle zone di pesca locali
ma chi minchia programmato sto gioco
perché mai dovrei discutere di zone di
pesca locali ma
perché cazzo state pescando dietro casa
mia me lo spiegate quali pesci
radioattivi possono esserci là dentro
non so io e come pescare sul naviglio
anche problemi a lei ma pescate a casa
vostra
quanto è difficile al giorno d'oggi
conquistare un po di patata due sono
andati o spariti tutti così tu a una
scelta sono spariti tutti quanti a me
comunque baia pesca visto che sono
curioso di capire come me c'è della
pesca al fuori dal mio giardino
non ho capito il perché fammi vedere
come bestie siano perché voglio capire
un attimo il problema che hai nell'avere
un pescato yo dietro casa
vogliamo farci un posto dove pescare
dietro gando sarebbe fighissimo
vai magnate magna desta bistecca farti
un insalata giardiniera ecco noi carlo
cracco in azione bravo zio
vediamo poi da puccini st insalata mi
chiama star certo accompagnare sono rai
la padella ripulisci ma poi pulisci
carlo cracco si può sempre accompagnare
sono se ti taglia un altro vinto può
accompagnare anche cesano di venerdì 13
è bella si salata alla sola pomodori è
diventata verde com'è possibile che chi
era con same per essere vicini a una
relazione amichevole cosa mi che è un
preludio di friends al telefono ma vi
rendete conto oppure uso del cellulare
da cellulare chiacchiere con katrina
caliente
con summer me sono legato aspro anche
katrina caliente non è niente male non
li che sarò troppo appiccicoso come il
ragazzo si potrebbe essere io sono
abbastanza e così il che potrebbe essere
un problema ma chi se ne frega la
battaglia è sacra minisiti è una visione
quella che vedo veloce veloce altri
veloce mica faccio colpo subito abbiamo
la porta blocca la forma come proprio la
porta governo che la porta mai a
raccoglierla no ma no che senza una
veloce ricaduta triste mi chiamano
regala riprese in tempo ma mi ama questa
donna via vas troppo è bellissimo la
doccia cassero vista del mio cestino mi
buttano immondizia ma tesoro to segniamo
a ieri ma quanti problemi o nella vita
prima perché ti porti via la meno dei
piani con abili boot mi ha buttato di
immondizia non ho detto niente non a
reggio in comprando una borsa di gucci è
già vissuta l'immondizia una cosa ma non
funziona così nella società odierna o
sbaglio mi chiama fantastico non sa che
io do rimorchiare il suo gioco bastano
il gioco un cazzo rimorchi e basta e
ferì bellissimo in vita dove la vuoi
invitare che non ce l'hai la macchia non
c'è manco la patente carta e una foto
insieme vai che faceva vedere a tutti
quanto siamo figli michael selphy così
tutte le mie passi cazzola morte ti
vogliono porta entro 5 minuti in
fantastico si sa dove va il giro dove
vari dove vai lui sta andando ma non
puoi si sapeva conosciuti ma tanto che
il caso di pigiama o io ho acceso ma io
faccio qualcosa si sta a casa dorme
rimorchio e basta cene senza non vado a
scuola faccia niente
si cacci
al top ma frate sede se devi andare al
centro lorenzo si trova a scuola hanno
nuovo capitolo ai domanda la scuola ma
tiene già minchia che periodi brutti
l'ultimo compito assegnato nella classe
di lorenzo è un progetto di gruppo i
suoi compagni sono tutti molto svegli
allora michael sommesso di merda lorenzo
deve contribuire tanto quanto loro è
mica allora no niente io posso portare
il caffè se vogliono sono le tre del
pomeriggio bene a chi sei messaggiando
zio sono una tipa devi avere in testa
arrestare una potete vedere ragazzi solo
per le signore questa cosa solo per le
signore
tutte le ragazze che stanno guardando
questo video io ci terrei a dire che se
fossi veramente io questa persona in
realtà la censura in questo momento
sarebbe così quindi non siate tv del
signore non settimana però una voce un
po meno omosessuale potevo mettermi al 4
quando sono andato a scuola la vescica è
tornata normale quindi sono andata a
scuola solo per fissare mi chiama da
quanto è difficile rimorchiare tipa
giorno d'oggi incredibile fi
un'imitazione sequestrato fare bene
basterà tutto teme vaccino dalle
groelandia valli per è entrata prende la
libertà si è lavata le mani ha visto che
faccio limitazione di salute antonio in
serata alle mani commenti sulla carriera
o ma lo sai che io ho 4 milioni di
iscritti sta mentendo e realtà non solo
3.950.000 ma lei non ci crede scatta
napoli insieme attenzione diventate
migliori amici
no quando vi si presenta questa opzione
no non è si non si diventa migliori
amici non si prendono le persone perché
anche lei vuole il birillo lovelli lo
leggo negli occhi
va bene dai prova ci prova ci prova ci
non importa migliori amici dai va bene
così per adesso con c'è lo step
successivo esiste scambio di battute con
una grande amicizia eterna monaca mi
sono auto film suonato secondo me la
posso far diventare più la mia ragazza
ne sono convinto perché se no non ci
sarebbe scritto amicizia eterna ste
cagate coap anno sarà mica la differenza
di età che lei una giovane adulta un
adolescente ma chi se ne frega il
birillo gioco stesso
per lei posso farla diventare la mia
ragazza aiuto ragazza tv dei consigli vi
prego non capisco ragazzi io per adesso
concludo qua sono troppo contento di
sotto del suo gioco perché troppo troppo
bello mi piace un sacco in parte lo
stupisco riportarci posta migliorino le
cose nel secondo episodio per adesso con
cui luca ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come semplice argomento che mi
piace anche vari social comitato una
descrizione fisica dei ci vediamo al
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]